El comienzo del año 2020 en China ha sido
más tormentosa que la relación entre Iker
Casillas y Joseph Mourinho.
A las noticias sobre la desaceleración económica
que han conducido al país a registrar el
menor crecimiento económico ni más ni menos
que desde el año 1990 se le ha sumado el
terrible impacto del “coronavirus”.
Acontecimientos que seguiremos y de los que
podéis dar por seguro os daremos todos los
detalles aquíen VisualPolitik.
Sin embargo, en esta ocasión os vamos hablar
de otras de las grandes amenazas a las que
se enfrenta el gigante chino, una amenaza
que puede cambiar por completo las expectativas
que muchos tenéis sobre la evolución geopolítica
de este país.
¿Habéis escuchado hablar de la política
del hijo único?
Pues, amigos… Ahora esa política que en
su día se vendió como un acción indispensable,
vital, ineludible para alcanzar el desarrollo
se ha dado la vuelta y se ha convertido en
todo un cuchillo que amenaza incluso el papel
de China como superpotencia mundial.
(Para que un país mantenga su población,
sin tener en cuenta los movimientos migratorios,
es necesaria una tasa de fertilidad de, al
menos, 2,1 hijos por mujer.
Es lo que se conoce como tasa de reemplazo.
En la actualidad, sin embargo, las mujeres
chinas tienen 1,6 hijos por mujer y la tasa
de natalidad ha caído de unos 20 nacimientos
por cada 1.000 habitantes en 1990 a poco más
de 10 en 2019.
O con otras palabras, los chinos tienen la
mitad de hijos hoy que hace tan solo 20 años.)
Amigos, todo esto os puede parecer a simple
vista algo poco importante, sin embargo lo
cierto es que sus consecuencias pueden llegar
a ser enormes… Especialmente en el campo
de la geopolítica internacional.
Es por eso que en el 2015 el gobierno chino
puso punto y final a la política del hijo
único y ahora, ahora buscan niños como el
agua de mayo..
Pero… ¿Qué está pasando realmente?
¿Qué ocurrió con la política del hijo
único?
¿Por qué ahora todo se ha dado la vuelta?
¿Qué tiene que ver todo esto con el futuro
de China?
Atentos.
(EL GRAN ERROR DEMOGRÁFICO)
Amigos, cada vez que los políticos juegan
a diseñar, moldear y construir sociedades
a su antojo, es carne de cañon para VisualPolitik.
Los resultados suelen ser nefastos.
[Ya sabéis, el papel lo aguanta todo.]
Pues algo así es lo que ocurrió en China.
La política del hijo único paso de ser un
alivio a convertirse en toda una pesada carga.
(Pero para entender realmente en qué consiste
el problema tenemos que remontarnos hasta
mediados del siglo XX.
En ese momento el gigante asiático aún no
había completado su transición demográfica,
es decir para que nos entendamos, las mujeres
aún tenían muchos hijos para compensar tasas
de mortalidad también muy elevadas.
Básicamente el escenario propio de cualquier
sociedad preindustrial.
Las tasas de mortalidad se reducen mucho más
rápido que las tasas de natalidad, lo que
provoca una enorme crecimiento de la población.)
Y es que es precisamente ese gap, esa diferencia
entre la caída de la natalidad que lo hace
lentamente y la caída de la mortalidad lo
que explica los grandes cambios demográficos
del último siglo y es, por ejemplo, lo que
ahora está ocurriendo en África.
Sin embargo, amigos, en el caso de China hubo
algo más: el gobierno de Mao promovía activamente
la natalidad.
La idea fundamental era que la mano de obra
disponible era lo que causaba el crecimiento
económico, de tal forma que cuanta más mano
de obra tuviese el país más desarrollo conseguiría
este.
(Una buena prueba de este espíritu la tenemos
a comienzo de la década de los 60 cuando
se produjo la gran hambruna que le costó
la vida a más de 15 millones de personas
como consecuencia del conocido como “Gran
Salto Adelante”, el segundo plan quinquenal
de Mao Zedong del que ya os hemos hablado
en algún que otro vídeo.
Tras semejante catástrofe demográfica el
objetivo del gobierno fue promover la natalidad
a toda costa.)
El caso es que entre unas cosas y otras, en
apenas 30 años la población se disparó
en casi 400 millones de personas,
Y fue exactamente ahí cuando los líderes
comunistas pensaron que todo esto de la natalidad
se les había ido de las manos y que de continuar
semejante crecimiento demográfico China nunca
conseguiría alcanzar el desarrollo porque
la población crecía tanto o más que los
recursos necesarios para mantenerla.
Por eso en 1979 el gobierno chino decidió
dar un golpe en la mesa y decir… vale, hasta
aquí hemos llegado.
Tenemos chinos por encima de nuestras posibilidades,
así que ahora quieto todo el mundo, un hijo
es suficiente y, como tengas más, te vas
a enterar.
Y así fue cómo llegó la política del hijo
único que permaneció en vigor hasta el 2015.
Únicamente en algunas zonas rurales y casos
concretos se permitía tener más de un hijo.
Hablamos de una política que, por supuesto,
tuvo consecuencias inesperadas.
(Se calcula que durante el tiempo que estuvo
en vigor la política de hijo único se terminó
con la vida de más de 360 millones de fetos
y niños ya nacidos.
¿La causa?
Por un lado, evitar las sanciones que imponía
el gobierno por inclumplir la ley.
Por otro, la preferencia que existió en China
de tener hijos varones sobre mujeres.
De hecho, este último fenómeno, esta última
salvajada hizo que en algunas regiones chinas
llegase a haber 125 hombres por cada 100 mujeres.
La ratio más desigual del planeta)
En fin, barbaridades que por supuesto han
sido duramente criticadas por las organizaciones
de defensa de los derechos humanos.
Y es que, amigos, la política del hijo único
se convirtió en la operación de ingeniería
social más grande y masiva que se ha llevado
jamás a cabo.
Y tal y como os podéis imaginar, tras casi
cuatro décadas de implantación estricta
de esta política, las consecuencias son enormes:
han dejado mella en la estructura social del
país.
Fijaos..
(A CHINA YA NO LE SALEN LOS NÚMEROS)
Los expertos lo tienen claro.
“China debería haber acabado con la política
hace 28 años.
Ahora es demasiado tarde” - Yi Fuxian, investigador
en la Universidad de Wisconsin)
Pero, ¿Por qué afirma Yi Fuxian que es demasiado
tarde?
¿Tarde para qué?
Pues… Amigos, fijaos en el siguiente gráfico:
Lo que podéis ver es simple y llanamente
un cambio radical en la estructura demográfica
china.
Un cambio radical que comienza con una pérdida
abrumadora de población.
Ese es el escenario al que se va a enfrentar
China durante las próximas décadas:
Mientras el número de niños menores de 14
va a caer considerablemente la población
mayor de 65 va a crecer de forma salvaje durante
las próximas décadas.
Y no solo eso.
Lo que es aún peor, se espera que la población
en edad de trabajar se reduzca paulatinamente
en cerca de de 200 millones de personas durante
los próximos 30 años.
Y de ahí a finales de siglo la cosa puede
ser mucho peor.
De hecho, de acuerdo con la propia Oficina
Nacional de Estadística de China, la población
en edad de trabajar comenzó a reducirse desde
el año 2012 y tan solo en 2019 se contrajo
en casi 900 mil personas.
Para que os hagáis una idea así es cómo
está cambiando la pirámide demográfica:
Es algo parecido a lo que va a ocurrir en
países como Singapur, Japón o Corea del
Sur.
Con una diferencia: China se va a enfrentar
a este problema cuando aún no es un país
desarrollado.
Y claro, con una población trabajadora menguante
y cada vez más población dependiente…
Los problemas no tardan en aflorar.
Y ahí no terminan los problemas: todos los
parámetros de la economía pueden verse afectados.
Por ejemplo, hasta ahora gran parte del crecimiento
económico de China ha procedido de la incorporación
de más y más trabajadores a la economía
productiva, sin embargo ahora eso está cambiando
y son muchos analistas apuntan a este hecho
como una de las causas de su desaceleración
económica.
Para colmo China es un país que aún está
en vías de desarrollo lo que implica que
tiene que intentar crecer rápido al tiempo
que se enfrenta a todos estos problemas.
Y eso no va a ser una tarea nada fácil.
Fijaos cómo pintan las cosas en apenas 30
años.
(Pero no hay que irse tan lejos: Un estudio
elaborado a 353 empresas de Sichuan, una de
las provincias chinas más pobladas, ha arrojado
el asombroso dato de que casi el 58% de las
empresas tienen problemas para cubrir posiciones
vacantes por la escasez de trabajadores.)
Tal vez por esto no debería extrañarnos
que a día de hoy China sea ya el líder mundial
en robotización industrial.
Actualmente tiene más de 150 mil robots industriales
en servicio, aproximadamente el 36% de todos
los robots industriales del mundo.
(De esta manera, el régimen de Pekín espera
multiplicar la productividad de los trabajadores,
o sea, mantener o incrementar la producción
con menos trabajadores, de modo que se pueda
mantener un buen nivel de vida para la gente.
Y ojo porque no es el único país que ve
en los robots su vía de escape al problema
demográfico.
Es exactamente la misma vía de escape que
persiguen en Corea del Sur, Japón y en practicamente
todos los países desarrollados.
Ante semejante envejecimiento sólo un crecimiento
muy fuerte de la productividad puede paliar
las graves consecuencias que puede tener desde
el punto de vista económico y social)
Pero amigos, la pregunta que nos podemos hacer
es….más allá de los robots, ¿Tiene este
problema solución desde una perspectiva demográfica?
¿Qué quiere hacer el gobierno chino?
Atentos.
(CUANDO EL DAÑO ESTÁ HECHO)
Cuando el daño está hecho, dar marcha atrás
resulta muy difícil.
Tantos años de ingeniería social han hecho
que la población china sea apática a formar
una familia.
Y no solo eso, la propia especialización
productiva del país tampoco invita a ello.
China ha crecido muy rápido durante las últimas
décadas pero sigue manteniendo niveles de
productividad relativamente reducidos.
Eso implica que el país se ha especializado
en competir en costes laborales por hora en
industrias muy intensivas en mano de obra.
Para que os hagáis una idea, la productividad
por empleado en Estados Unidos es casi 5 veces
más alta. Es decir que lo que produce un norteamericano por hora es equivalente a lo de 5 chinos
Eso implica que las jornadas de 12h o más
no sean algo extraño.
("China requiere cambiar su modelo de desarrollo
económico, pasando de la producción intensiva
en mano de obra y de baja calidad en los productos,
a la producción de bienes de alta calidad",
Dongxiao Qiu, director adjunto del Institute
for China and Global Development de la Facultad
de Economía y Negocios de la Universidad
de Hong Kong.)
El caso es que con semejante panorama profesional,
lo de tener hijos no parece una misión sencilla,
¿no os parece?
Pues… amigos, en cierto modo, estos dos
elementos, es decir la cultura gestada con
el paso de los años y la estructura laboral
están haciendo que el cambio de la política
del hijo único no sirva de mucho.
Y eso es lo que explica cosas como estas:
(Son ya varias provincias chinas las que están
restringiendo el aborto cuando hasta hace
poco tiempo lo promocionaban.
Algunas incluso han implementado la necesidad
de la firma de tres doctores para poder abortar.
Además, también, se están empezando a implementar
obstáculos para divorciarse.)
¿Será capaz el gobierno chino de obligar
a las familias a tener más hijos?
¿Tal vez establezcan privilegios ligados
al número de hijos o restrinjan el acceso
a servicios públicos o empleos si no se cumple
con la condicions de tener al menos 2 hijos?
Pues ojo porque eso es de lo que se está
empezando a hablar para combatir un tema que
puede lastrar no solo el desarrollo económico
chino sino también sus ambiciones geopolíticas.
Pero llegados a este punto, turno para ti:
¿Defenderías que el gobierno te obligase
a tener más hijos?
¿Qué crees que se puede hacer al respecto?